[Music]
Hello, welcome to Chat in the Arena, your
weekly podcast where we exchange
content that we've read, listened to, and watched,
always bringing a product perspective to the
discussion. I'm Artur, and today I'm broadcasting live
from the States. I'm... and
finally, I can say that my
move is over, two and a half weeks
later... Oh
my God, man, don't even talk to me about it,
you know... Anyway, in today's program, you
'll hear us talk about the following
topics: the news from Meta, the
new Lhama, the Ran, the drama in Brazil with AI and
Netflix, and the evolution of video products.
But before we get to the... there's a
weekly plug, as always, right? There's no way
not to have one.
Last weekend, last Saturday,
the third edition of the
AI ​​course for PMs took place, and it was great to have people
participating from all over the world. There were people
participating from here in the United States
as well, besides myself, and there were even people
from Malta participating. Look, here's a
curious fact: in the
first edition of the course, about 30%
of the people—we did a little survey
right at the beginning—only used AI
or...  Every day or even once a week,
now in the third edition, almost 90% of the
participants
used it between every day and once a week, so it's
evolving, right? We talk a
lot about it in the courses, but it's really
cool to see that people are also
using it much more often. That's
it, so the next class will be on
September 14th, online and live, and
that sweet 15% discount is in the
description here. And there will also be another
fifth edition of the
critical analytical thinking course with me and Dudu.
Well, we've run several editions
already, and now the next one will be on
August 24th. So if you want to learn
how to connect
financial indicators a little with the
interventions you make in the product,
stick with us, I'm cool.
Now, let's get to the agenda. Let's go!
[Music] Well, I
think we've already talked here
a few times about how Meta has
invested much more in the second generation
of HBAN than in the first, whether it's
investments in PR, events, etc. Even
for those who follow
Meta's Instagram, they did a series of
events, pocket shows, etc.  Where you used to have to
keep your phone at the entrance and
record and film everything with your
Riban, so you didn't
have to worry anymore about
wanting to see a show and having someone with
a phone in front of you, you know? I
talked about this a while back, remember when I
did it? See?
Anyway, this has had an effect, right?
In a recent conversation, the CEO of Luxottica,
the company that owns several
brands, including Riban itself,
commented that the new version has already sold
more in six months. Remember that it was
launched in October, and in six months it has already
sold more than the first generation in
almost two years. And one of the things he
said is that people's expectations
for V2 are much clearer now,
so this has helped us
evolve the product, people
understand how to use it, etc.
And there's been a
buzz that Meta will buy a
stake in
Luxottica, and there's also all the hype,
which I'll comment on in a moment, about how
my use is now that the functionality
is available to me.  Okay, I'll
tell you about my adventures in a moment,
including this business of Meta buying
a stake. Yesterday or today, I don't
remember, I saw that Google got involved
too,
so it seems there's competition, right? It's impossible not
to see the rich cousin doing what he
wants to do too, so
this world of Big Tex is all about that. But
how's it going? Wait,
I didn't understand what? Google wants to
buy a part of... it's the same... the
rumor arose that Meta wants to buy...
a stake in SL Luxottica...
Luxottica, I don't know the best way to say it.
Google would also be interested. Look at that,
just internet buzz.
Well, let's get to the most
interesting part, which is clearing up the first
doubt. Did it release for you because you're
in the United States, or was it already
working in Brazil? No, no, it's released.
I set foot in the States, I was already in
their Beta program, right? All
the updates, etc., but
specifically, it had never been released,
so it's only... it probably only works there...
no, no. So that's the point. In the beginning,
yes, but I
saw... I'm...  In a Reddit group here, for
people who use it, in the last two
weeks, several places in various parts
of the world have been saying that it's
allowed without using a VPN. You can do the thing, you can
always find a
way, right? But even without using a
VPN, there are some countries, like a guy
posted in Argentina, another in
London,
uh... Anyway, I think they're
starting to loosen up a bit more,
but for me, I think it
definitely... It identified my
IP, identified my
location, it's in the States, here in
Uncle Sam's land, it's allowed, allowed, fair enough.
And now with this mess that
happened here in Brazil, we're also
talking about it. I don't know if they'll allow it
in Brazil anytime soon. Because...
But let's see if, now that it's
already allowed me,
when I go back to Brazil, I'll say, 'This
guy already has it,' and so on. I'll let it be allowed
in the bank. It's changed, right? Now you have it
enabled?
Yes. So, how's the use of
this thing going, man? First thing, it
's a really cool effect, you know?
I opened the app and it already...  Pim is
released for you, see here how it
works, I don't know what, etc. How
you can use it, there's an
important point: you have to authorize
it before. You didn't need to authorize
access to
your phone's camera, and now it has
the camera, I don't know, it asks for a
different authorization to
take pictures because it takes a
picture, right? You go and ask
it, "Look at me," blah blah blah,
whatever you want. But it does
this with the glasses' camera, right? Yes, but
it asks for authorization to
take pictures, and so on, it's a bit of a hassle. And so,
man, that's it, because... So,
this is a cool thing, and it's
a nice effect to take pictures,
ask things, and man, the precision is
very good. I was amazed by
several situations where I've used it,
and it brought a lot of realism, like, what it
was, you know? For example, is it a
useful use or just... I don't know yet. So this is
one of the points that I'm going to talk about
for my
use, the use I'm making now is...
Nerdola, you know, today, like, "Oh, I want to
test this out here. Oh, see if this
identifies itself. What
is this? What am I looking at?" Okay, so
for my use it's not quite there yet, so I
still need to see how it will be in
daily use, even if it's
activated, if it's really practical in
everyday life. The bad part is two little things that have been
bothering me: uh, it's still kind of
slow, its processing isn't
that good, so it's not making
a device, right? It's sending it to your
phone, your phone is sending it to the
server, the server is processing and
sending it back, right? So, it takes a while,
it takes the process out and sends it,
so sometimes it takes a little while, so
sometimes it's literally easier to pick up
the phone and search for whatever it is
than to actually use it. Now,
another part, which is the part I didn't
like very much, is that it doesn't always warn you
that it couldn't analyze it, you know?
So you click there, it makes the little
sound that it's processing, but sometimes
it responds, saying, "Hey, I couldn't
take the picture here, I couldn't
identify this, I couldn't understand what
you said."  Sometimes he
just processes things and doesn't
respond at all, you know? It's like the
error message that's missing, like, "
This connection timed out,
waiting for a response." And he doesn't tell you about
that. Exactly, exactly. Do
a test for me and post it on Arena. Like, since
you're in the States, see
if he translates a sign you're looking at,
because I think it's a
really cool case for people who don't
speak other languages. That way we can connect, you know? Right away,
the person doesn't
need to speak, but they can
navigate a place with this, right? Post
it on Arena's Instagram. Okay, I'll do it, I'll
do this test. And
another cool thing is that he saves
the images you asked him about, the images
you talked to him about. He
saves those images, so later you can
see them all. When
he captured the image, he
saves that image and it's available
to you in one of the... everything
he took and what
his response was, you know?
And you can have interactions that aren't just... "
Tell me about this image, this..."  Photo type
you can use like you use an Ultra
LLM if you want to ask anything
random you can you can cool uh-huh good
cool yeah
and I think there's a cool hook
there for the second topic which is about
Llama 3.1, right? Which is the new version of
Facebook's LLM that you mentioned, man, it
's kind of slow so sometimes it's better to
grab your phone and stuff,
and today Meta announced their new model,
right, Llama 3.1, which is simply
a 45 billion parameter model,
so it's a gigantic model. But they
also updated the
8-bit 70-bit models, and they say in the
press release that the thing
they're going to work on more is on-device
models and multimodal models, right?
So the on-device models clearly
have a use here, which is, how do you
do this processing
on the device so that the return is
faster, right, for someone who's wearing
glasses, for example? But talking about the
main things about Llama 3.1, right?
I think the main point here
is that it's a model that people call a
Frontier Model, right? So it is  A
cutting-edge open-source model is the first major
cutting-edge open-source model like
Meta's previous models. They
were quite capable, but they were
capable in the
3.5 line, right? Chat PT 3.5. This model, at
least in benchmarks, rivals
and even surpasses, in several
scenarios, the for0 model and even the
Claud 3.5 model, which has
been said to be the best current model.
So I think that's the most
impressive thing: the cutting-edge model is
released with all the weights unlocked,
which people can use however they
want. They can make
commercial applications, they can train other models, they
can generate synthetic data, they can create
smaller models. So now it's in G's hands
to use a really awesome model however they
want, so the sky's the limit, right?
Let's see what
happens, right? But some
interesting data that's cool to
talk about in this release, which
Zberg even posted a big test
about, but let's go. I think the
first item is that this version is still
just text, right? It doesn't have the
IM part yet, although...  In the papers, they
talked so much about the translation, about how
it's capable of identifying and
generating text, but the window, from
what they said and in the tests, is
that it can process a piece of data
up to a book of about 50 pages and
everything else. It's
not a 128k
context window, I think it's more
than that, I don't remember exactly how much 128k is.
From what I saw, it was about a
page of about 50. But anyway, anyway, one
thing is
curious, actually one I'll leave for the
end because it's related to
this line. Actually, I'll say
something here: they haven't shared
where the training data is coming from, which
is that eternal discussion of, like, "They're
using the data, including..." There was a big fuss in
Brazil about that, right?
They were
using data from Brazil too,
etc., and then there was a big fuss there. They
asked for it, they canceled it, they
blocked it, they're not training with
data from the network of networks.  Social media
platforms like Instagram and Facebook in Brazil...
but another relevant piece of information is that
they used synthetic data for fine-
tuning, right? And we've already
talked about synthetic data in some episode,
and just to remind everyone about
this item... it
's somewhat generated data, right? It's fake data,
and that's something that
's not usually recommended,
especially in the training phase and
everything else. They used it and
said it worked very well.
Another point they mentioned in
the press release is
that they didn't separate the
percentage of test data
that was synthetic and the percentage that was
real data.
And they
also released smaller models, right?
They updated the 8-inch model,
exactly. And just to talk about
synthetic data quickly, like we're
talking about here... It might seem like the
model is worse because it's training on
data generated by the machine itself,
right? But no, because we
'll certainly see that in future updates,
whether of the OpenAI models or in
our...  The models from other companies, and it's almost a
consensus among experts,
simply don't have
enough data left to train on in
several iterations of these models. So,
synthetic data will have to be produced. This is a path that
most likely all of them will take. And
in the end, there are benchmarks to later
discuss the quality of the output of these
models, right? So, regardless of how
they are being trained, if in the end
the benchmarks are improving, and
obviously we as a society have to
increasingly evolve the
benchmarks we have because
we also know that these models
are getting better and better at passing
tests, not only in real-world use, but it's
something that will probably happen to everyone. And
then the
last item is also interesting,
especially since it's also
open source and everything else. They
also released a series of tools to
help identify when the
answer is correct or when the answer has
problematic issues, etc.
Anyway, they also made
an RFC, a request for comments,
for the Lhama API, so they're
calling it Lham.  So,
their idea is to make it increasingly easier
and more accessible for developers to use
the models that are already available in all
the major cloud providers, including
Hugging Faces, but they
are also starting to work on this and are
asking for community contributions on
how we can make this set of
APIs better for you. So, they are
embracing the idea of ​​being the open-
source option for this new computing platform. So,
the options
being offered and the path they
are following are very good. And I think
lastly, you already mentioned it briefly, but
there was news this week about Meta in Brazil
that they would be
training on their JI tools in
Brazil. There was an issue
with the ANPD (National
Data Protection Agency), Meta wasn't
following the agency's recommendations,
and they could face
a fine – I don't
remember the exact amount, but a
high daily fine. So, what they decided
was to temporarily stop the training with
Brazilian user data and
also take down the
DNI tools that were already available.  Available in Brazil,
right? Maybe one risk of your R-meta
not working in Brazil is that,
right? But for example, there was the
WhatsApp sticker tool and stuff that was already
released, and they gave it a little R-meta while
they resolve this issue. The metric was R$
50,000 per day of non-compliance here, right?
Imagine that, buying and
translating that into diapers, man, that
's your conversion metric now, right?
Everything becomes
diapers, it's tough, my friend. That's it, that's it.
[Music]
That's today's second piece of content, it's about
Netflix. We're going to comment a bit
on the report "Inside Netflix Batch on
Advanced Video Encoding" by The
Verge, which we always recommend here, right?
One of our favorite
tech news sites. And just to give a
quick context of how I ended up on this
content, right? I'm a huge video nerd here.
I worked with streaming for a
few years at Esporte Interativo, right?
So even more than Artur, because I
got more into the operations side and stuff at
one point, and because of that, I still
have a lot of interest in the
technical side of video distribution. But
this text doesn't only make sense for
video nerds.  That's why we
brought this up; it's a cool topic
about the company and its evolution because the
central point of the text is to talk about
all the encoding technology, which is
basically how you compress
a video, that Netflix has developed over
time, and all the insights
they've had to make it
increasingly efficient and better, both for the
user—super important—but also
for the company's bottom line, right? Everyone
ultimately wants to improve their dashboard. So,
for example, in the beginning, they encoded the
entire video, a movie, an entire series, in
the same way, using the same technique and
the same tools. And then, over
time, they realized that they
could encode each frame or each
block of frames of a video in a
different way, depending on what it was. So,
if it was an animation, they encoded it
one way; if it was a scene within a
series, they encoded it another way; if it was an
action scene, they encoded it another way. So they
moved towards being increasingly
efficient, almost frame by frame, in the
content we watch. There are
several other things here that I found
interesting, but I also wanted to see what you,
my dear Artur, liked about this
text. I think it was a...  This is a
lesson about various things, and if the
text is long, it's even worth mentioning that the
text is quite long, it's quite long, but it's cool to see
various concepts from the day-to-day of product development,
things that we talk about
here in the episodes. I think one of the
first things that really stood out to me
was how
they changed their tactics, which is the thing
about revisiting the product, which
is something we should
always be doing. They used to
encode everything, and then you think, "No, man, can't we
encode frame by frame here?" or "Can we
do something else?" or "Can we
add more intelligence here to
pick up specific things, specific contexts,
specific
video categories?" So I think that's it, right? In
our work in product development,
sometimes we end up going too deep, getting too caught up
in the day-to-
day, forgetting to take a step back
to think about the bigger picture, like, "Okay, we're
good," which is
something Lucas talked about in the last
episode we recorded here, something
that I...  I always challenge
anyone who works with me, who
's part of my teams, like the "what if" team, by asking, "What
if we did this thing
another way? Would it be
better? Would it be cheaper? Would it be
more practical? Would it give us more insights?"
So I think those are things
I thought were really, really
cool to see.
And what you said about "what if" is
interesting because it's related
to something else, which is... I don't remember if it was
one of the presidents of Netflix, one
of the directors there in content...
Revisiting here, he says that the
business was important for them,
even looking at new content, right? Live
games are about thinking differently than
they did for VOD streaming,
which is the VIDEO content we
talk about, and I think that's exactly what you said. It's
ICI, and it's an ICI that's
more about what we've already done. It's not ECI, but it's based on
what we've already done. It can also be a
basis, but it's a different ECI. And
they even say, "We can
do frame-by-frame encoding of VOD
because you know exactly what's
coming next in a
live sport, for example, in WWE, which they're going to
start broadcasting. You don't know what
the next frame is, so you have to be
even more proactive.
Maybe all the breakthroughs you
had to get to this technology
will have to have other breakthroughs
now for the next steps, right?"
And that's another
interesting challenge to talk about. They had a
context, which was launching
Video On Demand, etc., and now, when they... The
business strategy of growing in
both moments, right? There was a first...  Back
in 2015, it was like, "Let
's go all over the world, so
we're going to deal with places that have
much worse internet and everything else,
worse devices,
etc." So, okay, we need to review this, we
need to see how we
adapt, and there's another evolution of the product and an
evolution of the strategy, right?
Okay, now we're going to go
live, which is a
very different context. And they
even mention when they
tried to follow the same thing they
did in the VOD, in the
live launch of "Love is Blind," the
reunion episode of "Love is Blind" in the
US, and it went wrong, there were
problems. They said, "We can't
do the same thing, right? How do
we reinvent this? Change it because,
damn, now we're going into another
field." And I was remembering, remembering
this, from the time I worked
with micromobility at Yello, the aspect where
first we launched the bikes and
then we launched the scooters, which
was another context, you know? Although it was
also a vehicle, it was a different
context of use and everything.  But there were other
things involved, even in the... in the... there's...
later when... in the Bike
Itu... when we launched the
electric bikes, it was like a normal bike, it was
one thing, an electric bike was another
way... so that's it, man, how to reinvent
the product based on this evolution of the
product... you need to have a different perspective, you
start to have different perspectives on things, right?
Totally, I think that was
one of the things I found most
interesting, making this connection
with the day-to-day product, which is even
a company the size and
technical competence of Netflix... damn, they
are technically very good, they have
difficulty doing things that are
adjacent, right? Or doing something
completely different, which is exactly what
you said, man, making scooters is
an adjacent thing, making bicycles, making
electric bicycles is
adjacent to making bicycles, you
weren't making bicycles and then you went to make airplanes, you know?
You went to do something
close there, and it's difficult because the
skills you developed as a
company to do that first
thing very well won't necessarily
be the skills to do
that second thing very well, and I think there's an
exercise in humility
here that they say, man,
when you...  If you're going to do something new, it's no use
optimizing right away because
you don't know how to do it. So it's no use
trying to optimize right away to have the
best cost, the best margin for the business.
Obviously, in a business where you can
afford that freedom, you know? So start with
the business definitions, create the
industry standard, and then you
learn to optimize with VOD itself.
That's what they did, right? They were doing the
industry encoding, then they optimized,
helped create new codex there along
with the industry, and then they arrived at this
breakthrough. Right away, you know,
frame by frame, do this, like, "Wow,
we did frame by frame," but there are
scenarios here where it didn't look so
good. Whatever the next thing, but I
think it's really cool. Just
because you're really good at one thing doesn't
necessarily mean you'll be good at something
very similar, right? So that
's really cool for a company
like Netflix, right? And these
new challenges, it's curious that they're doing
two things at the same time, right?
These new challenges are clearly
expansion, right? Of the live streaming,
we've talked about it several times, right?
The live sports things
they're doing, but not just sports,
they've done specials of...  The live comedy
you mentioned, like Love Is Blind,
they're experimenting with that, and
obviously, because when they have to
do live esports and do
something like WWE, which has the highest audience
on the network in the
United States for I don't know how many
years, you know, every year it's
consistently the highest audience, they
have to do it well. So they have to have
mastered at least part of that so that when
prime time comes,
they do it super well. And then there are games,
which is another thing, because
they stream games today on
Netflix, right? So you go there, go to the
server, and it comes back to your TV or
your cell phone, but even though it's
similar to live content, there's an
issue that doesn't exist in live content, which is the
player input, right? You pressing
buttons, moving things from one side to the other, which
is a completely
different encoding challenge. There's a
really cool podcast from The Verge,
The Decoder, with one of the CEOs of
Netflix, where he talks a little
about these gaming challenges and the
difficulty of having to encode
differently, and where they're going with
that. We'll leave the link there.  In
the push description, also... Uh-huh. And the
last thing before we
finish this block, something you
mentioned, right? They set up
new codex and everything, and they also
trained models in partnership with
a university in California to
develop
new models using machine learning, etc., to
analyze video quality, etc.
And the coolest thing is that they made
this model open source afterward, right? So it
's cool to see these movements of
partnership, right? Between the more academic and perhaps
not just theoretical part,
the academic part, but with
a mega-practical application that then
returned to the market as a whole, and
everyone started using it, right? And that's something
I see several
companies doing, right?
Airbnb, when they launched LoR
for animations and stuff. So, it
's cool to see this kind of thing, right? Totally.
And at this point, they made a
12-minute film specifically to
serve as a benchmark for codex and
liberal incode models, like, "
This is the new
industry standard for you to validate and
things like that."  Releasing it
to others also connects
with the topic of the first
Facebook segment, which is: Facebook isn't
releasing the G and open-source models
because they're nice, you know?
Purely because, man, there will be a lot
of people building on top of it,
making it better, and it
goes back to Facebook as a
better product for them to use.
Besides, it trains people who
will eventually work at Facebook in the future,
right? So you
create technology, you give it to people,
this technology becomes an
industry standard, man, when you're recruiting,
everyone uses your technology, you know? This
happened with many things on
data platforms, I think there are several examples like that, but there are
many things where this happened.
So the circle closes here between our
second and our first content, that's it,
man, that's the connection here, and let's go to the
products of the week. Let's go!
[Music]
Ah, so it starts. You telling me what
your product was last week,
man, the product of last week... I'm even going to
end up talking about
other people here too, but it was
Amazon, right? Mainly because I'm
here in the States and here we have
real Prime, you know,
the full Prime, there were things here.  Well, I
even think this year was a little better than
other years here in Brazil, but there's no
comparison. Unos, man, there were things
with literally, I don't know, 50, 70%
off, you know? And things... it's not like
leftover stock, you know? So, damn, it was
great. And then there's another one
that I always use a lot when
I'm here, which is StockX.
Basically, for those who want a
reference, StockX is like Dropper in
Brazil. Dropper was kind of copied,
I don't know. It's
for buying sneakers or
rarer items, specific things,
sneakerhead stuff. But they don't
just have bags, they have a lot of other things
too. But man, I
particularly like it a lot. It has
a feature where you can bid on the
sneakers instead of paying the
full price, you can negotiate.
So there are some cool things like
that. And in a little while I'll also
show you which
collectible sneakers I bought this
time. Okay, I'll take this opportunity to talk about mine
here because it also relates to Prime
Day.  Just to digress a bit, I
used Twitter and Telegram a lot to see
the Prime Day deals. On
Twitter, mainly @
chatdpromoções, and there's another one I
forgot now.
On Telegram, there's a channel I'm even opening
here to see, called Caçadores de
Ofertas (Deal Hunters). So I'm always
visiting those deals websites, you know,
Get Try HardMOB and stuff. And I was
following those
live streams on those channels during
Prime Day, and it was cool, man. And then I was
like, V and Mexe,
giving that little push to the
consumerism button, you know? "Damn, this thing here that
I didn't need, but it's at a good price,
let me buy it!" And with a new house, you know, it makes you
want to buy everything new too. Yeah, yeah, it
's very good. And our listeners here
sent Prime, Amazon too, Amanda,
Henrique, there were
several
physical products today,
Karina Sato and the people from Docket
sent the bblend, everyone has a
bblend now, and ABL in a
bottle, exactly. They launched a
bottle version of that, you have the
machine, I have the machine, and...  A
while back they released a little bottle
to simulate the machine,
and people are using it a lot. Andrezinho
sent a board game called Azul, he
said he played it a lot. I thought it was
from Azul. Pan is... damn! Andrezinho
sent the anime crunch roll and
everything. Lucas sent Snowflake, he said
their new function helped a
lot, it's much easier to
generate queries and everything. Glauco
sent Vivino, Anana sent Strava,
Victor sent Squad Busters. Caco
sent the
Pilon app, which is also changing, she's
also in the same situation as us. She said they have
n't installed internet at
her house yet, but she's using
Claro Wi-Fi there and it's working great.
So she said, "Man, it's working."
So that's a lot of stuff,
keep sending us more,
we know we ask at the
last minute and before recording, but whenever
you remember, send us some on
Prod Arena's Instagram, on my
Instagram, on Artur's Instagram, and
we'll bring it here.
[Music]
here.  So, that concludes
this week's program. A
few messages from the Parish, as
always: follow us if you listened! If
this program was forwarded to
you, and you're not yet following us on
your favorite podcast player, go ahead and give us
five stars, leave a comment!
You can leave comments on Spotify,
but you can also leave
comments on YouTube and Substack.
Any and all engagement you
do greatly helps the podcast grow and
train the algorithms on social media,
saying, "Look, people are enjoying this, I'll
recommend it to more people!" So help us out!
And you can also recommend something you heard here
that you think someone you
know will enjoy. Tell them, "Listen to
Popo na Arena Podcast, those two
guys are cool!" So recommend
it!
We almost forgot to celebrate, did
n't we? We reached the
Apple Podcasts top 30 again! Now we have to
reach the top 20! Our mission is to
recommend one more person. If everyone
who listens to this program
recommends one more person to listen, we'll
reach the top 20! For sure!
So help!  We're following
us on social media, right? The
usual complaint and message @x @arthur Close
comk @ product Arena So follow us there
and that's it, see you next week Arthur, see you
my dear. Oh, one last important piece of information
here, right? Oh yeah, let's see, what's the
update on Eve's size? Wait a minute, I'm
here, look, this week she's the size
of a penguin or a... a
combo of
pancakes, a completely
random combo of pancakes. That's right,
no, a combo is a bunch of
stacked pancakes, this analogy makes no sense at all. We're done with
pancakes and penguins, see you
next week, pancakes and penguins, see you.